[Musique]
ces mythes heures passent et à 55 c pas
vous êtes en train de cheminer vous
entrez vous sortez vos cartes du centre
c'est son pseudonyme la cicciolina
brigitte bardot brigitte bardot tu te
prends rendez-vous affaires sociales
était d'accord avec ça ah ouais
vous les chouchouter trop et c'est pour
ça qu'elle revienne chez vous seulement
4% sont arrivés à se réinsérer
on peut pas continuer à dépenser sans
résultat on peut plus qu'est ce que
c'est que ça au revoir jean callet si
réparer des trucs ça se trouve les
autres aussi s à faire des choses c'est
peut-être comme ça qu'on peut les aider
en gt2 soignante
moi j'ai travaillé dans une immobilité
les savoir en combien de temps un jour à
ces 24 heures c'est beaucoup
on va vous confronter au monde du
travail
j'ai 56 ans rappelle les dix dit non tu
t'appelles pas lady di est ce que tu es
lady di non tu donnes ton vrai nom
réserve de l'électroménager les
appréhende raison après j'ai tué mon
mari attend chantale j'aime pas
m'enterrer vêtements audriel dit pas
qu'elle a un problème avec les hommes
attends je moi j'ai aucun problème avec
les âmes voilà audrey la halle mot et
c'est pas grave je vais rapporter des
luminaires de chez moi
comment veux-tu qu'elle soit autonome si
tu marches tout pour elle t'as pas vu
dans leurs regards l'espoir qui revenue
tu sais pas comment elles sont belles
comment elles ont envie maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
folie dit c'est la plus moche qui trouve
un mec est pas mal qu'ils aient attendu
d'engins il
[Musique]